it's time to play OverWatch 2 but
because I'm a real life doctor I'm gonna
play as a Healer and see how that
compares to the treatments that I give
in the hospital
OverWatch to new Heroes not really new
maps I don't know why we have to
remember this game is free I think this
game is free is the game free yeah I
think it's a free one it's a free one
that people spend their money on in all
my years of practice all my years of
healing patience thousands of patience
this is where it gets shown I throw the
best balls the best healing balls or
their orbs
I am going to select my hero and my hero
all the time Moira and I have no skins
check this out just one and two I
probably should buy one for the game at
least to look cool let's see we got on
my team we got a Lucio a torb zarya and
whatever this new guy is I forgot his
name I'm very strategic in this game
it's very surgical if you will like see
right now we're already overextended the
zarya is gonna get clipped early
I can't even do a lot of healing here
look at this micro macro
torb healing torb oh I have nope we
gotta go this way oh I think this Ryan
got me I think this Ryan got me oh we
already got crushed here I'm gonna feed
my team and heal them up pretend I'm
performing surgery always keep an eye
out if anyone else is coming oh we're in
trouble I'm gonna back up and minimize
the losses for my team here
yeah this is no bueno here I'm going to
throw an early orb
I don't want to use my old right away I
want to keep my teammates up here
remember when you're throwing healing
orbs you got to think about the bounce
okay so here I'm going to try and be
aggressive on this Rhine and pocket our
torp while doing some damage
get a nice pick there keep our Winston
up our Winston's diving come on Winston
get us a shield Bud get us a shield I'm
pocketing you get the get the mercy get
the mercy you know we don't like
competition in the Healer space I love
the damage balls orbs look at that Dodge
look at that you weren't even ready ah
look that's how I am in the boxing ring
except against Chris Avila why is our
Winston up there like that I've got to
keep the balance oh I got pinned
how did he go through everyone else and
pin through me I gotta watch this replay
bro he's he made a left turn you're not
supposed to be able to move left and
right when you're charging as a right
taking the loss is sometimes more
important than getting a win
especially when it comes to OverWatch
and OverWatch is a frustrating game
because you got to play as a team most
people are not on voice chat oh great we
had our team member lead we had a team
member leave you know what this is not
teamwork this is why OverWatch
frustrates me I just spent 10 minutes of
my life trying to win this fight and now
I can't even win this fight because my
teammate decided to leave look at this
look at this pocketing look at his
pocketing
this guy's literally not even moving
bro get the rhyme
oh no
okay I'm gonna try and do some damage
instead not that it's gonna do much look
at this look at this terrible damage
output by Moira I hope I got a pin again
and they score now everyone's leaving
okay so I'm leaving too
sad why people suck why leave I know
tour of God one three one three by the
way great username I can't carry a team
of five as a Healer yo torb god let's
hope no one quits this time he's gonna
be you're a loser all right we got two
healers Zen we got torb and tour of God
everyone loves this Sigma character I
think Sigma is confusing to play oh now
he's doomfist
I've never seen a good doomfist okay
early start I'm gonna get a little
healing orb going I like to throw my
healing orbs a little earlier in
prediction because oh man Diva you're so
overextended how am I supposed to help
you without going all the way in
throwing the orb early is like
preventive medicine except that you can
recover faster
so here I'm gonna try and do uh
damage Moira oh look at that look at
that big big brain move oh he's getting
pocketed come on see I'm pulling two of
their team members away that was
actually a good move on my part
now I'm going to try and heal our Diva
through that balance look at that bounce
look at that bounce
[Music]
yo please tell me you saw that balance
that was a big brain bounce big brain
fade into my own healing orb look at
that look at this healing you guys can't
pay for this level of healing health
insurance does not cover this level of
healing I only have 3 000 healing
there's a junk rat guys there's someone
on point there's a sigma on Point Let's
there's a healing orb for a diva keep
pushing I like to stay behind this thing
as much as I can so they don't get like
a cheap headshot on me keep bouncing the
orbs five seconds for next orb
um probably gonna go this way with the
orb heal up our Diva and we score
that was because of that orb that one
orb
no copay easy clap
easy clap easy clap yeah
um yeah basically but like if you get
clapped that means like you got like
destroyed and easy is easy easy clap GG
Noob that's my favorite but no one says
that anymore my favorite is when people
start the game and they say GL HF yo
good luck have fun
glhf at least say it back
what are you eating though
Hot Cheetos I hope you get pics we can
easy clap they changed this map a little
bit
yeah no it's not even snowing the bus
moved like an inch I used to be able to
throw an orb right from the door on the
right side of the bus how am I going to
this kid oh I killed him he's killing me
okay easy easy clap okay easy clap watch
this watch Mr widow's not ready for this
[Music]
bro the the Widow ain't ready for my
balls my orbs
Broome fish is killing everybody when
the doomfist hits you and he hits you
into a wall you get stunned I didn't
know this I gotta stay with the pave
is this load right here of Christmas oh
doesn't that looks nice bro
who's nice okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait we got it we gotta heal people up
Mercy I'm gonna rescue you yes look at
that Moira pocket
this doomfist is done this doomfist is
done that's right doomfist you done
oh how did the roadhog go down get this
road get this road get this nice got the
roadhog good picks massive heels massive
heels massive honor masavana
Oh No Mercy Mercy no mercy
oh mercy sorry you got pulled in all
right this is where we back up back up
back up back up
back up I'm gonna try and pocket you as
much as I can nope can't do it okay now
we're actually in a good position here
to push I'm gonna block the road head
hook roadhog hook with this get that Zen
here for an easy pick roadhog
he I just said I wanted to protect from
the roadhog hook God he didn't even mean
to go for me he meant to go for Diva
here's a healing ball oh you found them
you saw that Dodge or the hook you saw
that Dodge of the hook I am going crazy
I just made fun of the game let's go
triple kill Is A Healer what doctor do
you know that gets kills we're literally
about to win right now
oh my God bro what's wrong with our diva
they're destroying us we're dead they're
destroying us wow Diva why did you dive
like that just stick with the team I
have to go Mass healing here oh they're
Divas diving us like that
like that you're really gonna dive us
like that not when I'm healing now when
I'm healing now when I'm getting massive
heals how are they doing so much damage
output my God I can't throw orbs fast
enough look at that pocket look at that
pocket
look at this pocket look at this pocket
that's called pocket healing that's
called pocket healing
no what a long hook bro 14 000 healing
what more can I do I see squishies I see
squishies
you can't do anything huh
oh play the game
play the game and we lost MVP look at
this look at that pocket look at that
pocket roadhog roadhog Zen let's go
Reaper Anna Reaper Anna and the diva I
killed her whole team ridiculous people
wonder why gamers are always stressed
out you want to eat Taco Bell but you
still want to eat healthy well I created
a tier list of the healthiest foods you
can get in Taco Bell with my good friend
babish as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]